As you sit in the plane and try to relax, you have terrible thoughts such as:
What will happen if the plane door is opened?
Commercial aircraft raise pressure inside their cabins to match atmospheric pressure of 8,000 to 10,000 feet above sea level.
Although the cruising altitude of the aircraft on board is between 30,000 and 45,000 feet in the air.
Atmospheric pressure decreases as the altitude increases.
Due to the gravity of Earth clouds on atmospheric particles in the atmosphere.
The closer you get to the surface of the earth, the stronger these molecules.
The pressure will be reduced in less than 0.5 seconds if the door is opened.
Will be thrown out of the aircraft as well as anything that is not installed if the seat belt is not attached
Due to different pressure
Survival rates in this default scenario are very low given the possibility of a full crash.
Because the air is lighter in high places, the oxygen content is lower.
The gradual decrease of pressure in the compartment causes the oxygen mask to fall from the top
You will have an average of 18 seconds to put the mask before you become hypoxic.
Oxidation occurs at low oxygen levels and causes symptoms including dizziness, nausea and loss of consciousness
Leading to death.
The remaining oxygen will remain in the aircraft for 10 minutes
It is enough time for the pilot to land quickly by 8,000 to 10,000 feet
To balance external and internal pressure and give you hope of survival.
Have you been in a panic yet?
Do not worry, the chances of opening the door are very small
This is because the actual pressure is eight to ten pounds per square inch of the plane.
Remember that the pressure inside the cabin is higher than outside.
For example, we will introduce the largest commercial aircraft, the Airbus A380,
Where the main door weighs 4288 square inches,
It requires 38,592 pounds of power to open it.
This is equivalent to trying to move 3 African jungle elephants -
It is the largest mammal on Earth.
In addition, the door of the aircraft is always closed automatically by the pilot
Through functions that can be accessed from inside the cockpit only.
To lessen your fears:
It will be almost impossible for any individual to break you and the window of the plane.
These windows are made of six layers of different types of strong anti-bullet polymers.
Furthermore, these windows are always round to minimize attraction during flight,
This prevents cracking and low pressure.
Your death toll in a car accident is 1/114 higher than that of an aviation accident
Compared with 1/9821 incidents related to air travel.
So, fasten your seat belt and watch the video safety instructions, and above all enjoy your trip.
Thanks for watching the video, do not forget to subscribe to the channel,
We publish a new science video every Thursday.
And click the bell icon seems to have a function.
If you want to watch more videos now, we'll put links to some videos here so you can lose them
To satisfy your need for knowledge,
Otherwise, we'll see you next Thursday in a new video.
Bye!